depuis longtemps à ottawa et l'eldorado
des soins de santé pour les résidents de
gatineau avant la pandémie traverser la
rivière des outaouais pour des raisons
médicales tenait de la routine et
pendant des années la capitale nationale
était l'un des seuls moyens pour avoir
accès à la procréation assistée
j'avais vu un article d'un journal qui
parlait d'une clinique d'infertilité à
ottawa louise avait déjà deux enfants
lorsqu'elle a visité la clinique du dr
barwin neuf mois plus tard elle donne
naissance à une fille marie-pierre elle
s'est juré de ne jamais lui révéler le
secret de sa conception
je voulais pas chambouler sa vie j'avais
pas dû briser le coeur elle va pas
qu'elle prenne mal en arménie borwin les
couples de la région trouve un mètre de
l'insémination artificielle
c'était vraiment la clinique c'est en
1987 que léonie et marc bouvier consulte
le médecin j'ai été chanceuse dalphond
parce que premier essai je suis devenu
un salarié tel bon dieu
les chemins se croiseront à la même
époque
étudiant en psychologie il côtoie
régulièrement le médecin il devient même
donneur de sperme c'est clinique ses
succès seront reconnus à l'échelle
nationale mais deux décennies plus tard
la chute
il représente une centaine de personnes
dans un recours collectif contre
numberwin selon lui 75 enfants n'ont pas
été conçu avec le sperme identifiés par
les parents et 16 de plus sont les
enfants biologiques du médecin ces
allégations n'ont pas été prouvées en
cour et norman baroin a refusé de
répondre à nos questions mais lorsque
son ordre professionnel l'a radié l'an
dernier il a ni contester ni admis les
allégations pour m crown
il faut maintenant penser aux victimes
cette saga incitera louise a brisé son
silence sur coup c'est ce que je disais
ben ça change harry s'était plus rendu
chez moi après quand j'ai refusé à
succès comme quitte mon père c'est pas
mon pare de simplicité un peu plus un
choc d'apprendre
marie-pierre fera un test adn organisée
par les avocats
le résultat est formel nous emmène
balwin et son père
c'est important de connaître ton
identité j'aime ses deux sabots vraiment
2 août vient marie-pierre se joint alors
à un groupe dont fait partie rebecca
dixon c'est elle qui a initié le recours
collectif
selon son décompte il y aurait neuf
enfants biologiques en ontario 3
colombie britannique et quatre au québec
je m'attendais pas de trouver deux
personnes dans le même mois
quatre ans depuis qu'on a commencé que
cette expérience mais pour moi ça m'a ça
m'a indiqué que c'est au québec qu'on va
peut-être qu'ils couraient de personnes
trente ans après la naissance de leur
fille annick marque ailée on y voit
aussi un reportage sur rebecca d'exxon
ils sont bouleversés le doute qu'ils ont
ils commencé à réduire à cause justement
de nous une certaine ressemblance
physique alors c'est là que c'est devenu
que les échos dion il faut absolument
c'était quelque chose qui était quand
même assez douloureux pour moi mais
j'étais quand même contente de te
connaître la vérité annick n'est pas la
fille du dr barwin est impossible de
dire si le médecin à respecter le choix
de ses parents pour moi instinctivement
tout de suite je voulais le connaître
mon demeure la recherche est cependant
difficile contrairement à plusieurs pays
comme la nouvelle zélande
les dons de sperme sont anonymes au
canada santé canada répond pas pouvoir
recueillir ou divulguer ce genre
d'information par l'entremise d'une
banque d'athènes en ligne annick
parvient finalement à trouver son père
biologique
il s'agit de moments forts
angie terrorisme comme annick hémeury
marie-pierre rebecca et les autres
enfants biologiques du dr barwin ont
vécu des changements profonds dans leur
vie aujourd'hui il demain régulièrement
en contact prennent à se connaître et
poursuivent eux aussi leur quête
[Musique]